twas the night before Christmas at site
88 and Robert the guard was running
quite late all the skips were contained
in their cells with such care that
everyone hoped as did Bob they'd stayed
at his first order of business was to
check out containment he changed
channels instead to the night's
entertainment it's a wonderful life it
seen it before
and fell asleep then for an hour or more
there were those who had hoped on this
night before gifts that Robert would
draw the short straw on the sheds and
plans were hatched over seven months
previous by a group of some interest
with conspirators devious to release all
the creatures contain at the site to
fight the foundation on Christmas Eve
night they knew that their plan while
courageous was dumb but worth it they
thought if it releases just one it's one
two and three or as easy as pie but they
met the resistance at gates four and
gates five Bob started awake at the
sound of alarms and shouting and death
and of course firearms he switched his
molitor's checked all of the frequencies
if the red button for containment
emergencies all screens he could see as
they just laid it in no one could get
out but inside they could win they
planned well for that and taking their
chance the first cell on the right at
the placard they glanced and in looking
they saw their won 7-3 so you could and
thought how bad could it be a statue of
you so easily beaten but these stupid
folk hadn't been to that meeting so as
the last of their number closed his eyes
in assent I'll be blinked once and the
last father was bent he panicked then
and fell to the floor
scrambled had made his way outside his
door the statue that's right where he
would be as Bobby fell backwards
attempting to flee it pressed on his
windpipe strained vocal cords this is in
he imagined and the thought of last
words
Merry Christmas he croaked as it began
its attack merry Christmas to all and to
all a good
you
you